hi
in this video i'm going to talk about
numerical aperture of a microscope so
here is our simple
com a simple light microscope
so here what we see here is our uh
glass
by which the light would be reflected so
if light is coming like this
light would be reflected
and lightweight light would go from
these
condenser lens
and
uh
light would get into the specimen and
from the specimen light would again get
inside the objective
so if we zoom that thing
we zoom that whole thing
so here we have
our
microscope objective lens
here we have our
specimen suppose we have a cell on a
slide
here is our cell and here we have our
condenser lens
here we have our condenser lens
here is the light source
so for instance here is the light source
and the light path would be
from the light source light would be
first focused onto the condenser lens
then from the condenser lens what would
happen
light would go to the
specimen it would fall on the specimen
and then
from the specimen
again
light would be transmitted
to this objective lens
and
here i am drawing the
uh optical axis
this is the optical axis
and say for instance
this angle in the optical axis is alpha
let's for let's for a moment call it
alpha
and
numerical aperture is just defined as
the capability of this objective
lens to gather these
cone of light so the light coming from
the source
uh when reaches the
objective lens it appears to be a cone
of light the ability the availability of
the uh objective
lens to capture these cone of light is
known as numerical aperture so numerical
aperture is dependent upon two chain
thing one thing is
these angle this half angle with the
optical axis and also the numerical
aperture is dependent upon the
refractive index of the media
surrounding these slide so if we write
the
equation for numerical aperture it would
be numerical aperture which is equal to
mu
mu is here uh the refractive index of
the media for air it would be 1 if we
use the oil immersion lens it would be
like
greater than 1
and
times
mu times
sine
of alpha alpha is the half angle with
the optical axis
so for instance we have a
cone of light
and we have some angle alpha with the
optical axis
and now for a moment assume
we have another
cone of light
we've which have an angle
which have an angle alpha two
now
uh the objective
if we draw the objective here again
the objective is only able to
gather the light information which is
within this small cone of angle alpha so
if the angle with the optical axis is
pretty huge then the information which
is in this huge or this big cone is not
gathered by the objective that is why we
should always take care of the numerical
aperture and in the later videos we will
see that numerical aperture is also very
important for the resolution of a
microscope
and
also numerical aperture
we can also uh increase the numerical
aperture by using the oil
in the oil immersion lens for higher
magnification in the latter video we
will see these things